miss Shiva what do you criticize the g20
for oh I don't criticize the g20 I just
don't think that they are a source of
the solutions that we face today part of
it is they were created to deal with the
financial crisis and countries like mine
we had nothing to do with that crisis of
2008 have been drawn into the global
financial economy and are now in a deep
crisis so I see my main problem is that
it is enlarging the destructive forces
and their scope and their markets and
their reach the second is they are being
presented as more democratic than the g7
but they still under democratic when you
think of the hundred seventy five
countries left out when you think of the
people left out because there's no
process of really listening to people or
the millions of species left out because
the ecological language is too shallow
given that we've had an earth summit
which is given as treaties for species
conservation biodiversity conservation
binding UN climate framework all of that
is ignoring and there bits and pieces
picked up and because of worked in this
field now for so so long I can identify
how that jigsaw puzzle facts fits
together for the next step of corporate
takeover but isn't a good idea to tackle
the big problems like climate change
poverty international terrorism together
amongst those most powerful states first
of all we have international in treaties
with full multilateral participation
like the environment treaty CVD
desertification Convention on Climate so
it's not that g20 will do more than
Paris the best it can do is prevent the
dismantling and I think one thing g20
can do is one of the 20 is mr. Trump
call him to account he's a rogue among
the g20 sort out your matters if you
really have a deep power and a deep
commitment the second is
I think we need to recognize that the
roots of conflict are the same roots
that are destroying the environment a
war against the earth becomes a war
against people becomes a war against
livelihoods and securities
that's what's then fueling the
discontent whether the discontent is
harvested for a hate politics or the
discontent mutates into acts of
extremist violence the solution is
sustainability justice and remembering
that we on this planet everyone has a
right to share of the planet anyone over
exploiting the earth is stealing from
someone else and their consequences the
German government and g20 presidencies
before have met with civil society and
NGOs to hear their concerns so why do we
still need a summit like this but first
of all most of these leaders who are
gathering here are not just not
listening to their citizens at home when
the citizens whether it be farmers in my
country saying we are in deep debt
because of the chemicals and seeds and
we need justice they get bullets instead
of justice and we call our farmers and
ADATA those who give us food and we say
Anna data tsuki Bava
let there be wellbeing for our farmers
they need to be listening the farmers
they need to be listening to the young
people they need to be listening not
just when they come here but when
they're at home the g20 platform can
only be tested in terms of how each of
these members performs in terms of
democracy justice and sustainability in
the countries where they have being
given power and they have the power to
use that power either to facilitate the
destructive forces which is why I said
it's not that g20 has Sherpas the g20 is
the share part of the global economy or
1% and the test of a very precarious
future for most of humanity the
polarization of 1% in 99% whether they
work to create more security well-being
freedom for the 99% or will they be a
lubricant for the 1%
that's the issue thank you very much